Yeah,
the methods of developing drugs is sort
of set up so that you know,
you,
you try to control for a similar group
of people and you give them a similar
pill,
you know,
but the deal is,
um,
we don't know anything about their
genetics,
you know,
so maybe they have these certain enzymes
in their body that like,
really,
you know,
turn this drug over and turned it into
the active metabolite,
for example,
that helps you.
Or maybe you're a bad metabolizer and it
builds up in your liver and causes
problems.
I'm the deal is the pharmaceutical
companies would rather have,
um,
have their market not limited by 66
percent.
They would just like to sort of create a
drug for everybody,
throw it out to the mass,
the masses.
And I'm,
if it improves symptoms by five percent,
well it's a drug and it's done its job.
Um,
but it actuality,
whenever you look at it across the
population,
there's a significant amount of people
that are harmed by that drug.
The FDA tries to eliminate that as much
as possible.
Um,
but you know,
it doesn't always work.
I think that there are certain drugs
that are,
uh,
that we should not be taking.
Absolutely.
Uh,
in 2009,
the FDA approved only 26 drugs,
uh,
70 percent of those were me too.
Drugs,
drugs that were going off patent and
needed to be remarketed as you know,
the next purple pill,
for example,
in order to create,
you know,
a $400 a month blockbuster drug,
a in exchange for a $4 a month generic.
Um,
I think that that is a very,
very,
very shady practice and it's harming our
health,
uh,
in exchange for,
um,
creating a whole industry of
profitability off selling snake oil and
marketing gimmicks.